la crise des incendies qui ravagent
actuellement la forêt amazonienne sapri
vous le savez en des proportions
internationales
beaucoup s'inquiètent de la dégradation
de ce qu'on surnomme le poumon de la
planète
on va jeter un regard scientifique est
ce que la déforestation pourrait venir à
bout de cette grande forêt tropicale la
plus grande au monde
renault va nous guérir en gagne est avec
nous pour sa chronique scientifique
salle yves renaud baujot évolue donc on
aussi en le président brésilien a fait
appel à l'armée mais ce que l'armée peut
vraiment faire des miracles va se sont
énormes les feux de forêt qui font rage
actuellement on se demandait ce qu'on
arrive au point critique est
effectivement plus quand on entend
parler de point critique avec la forêt
amazonienne ça peut être un peu
surprenant pas ça reste une énorme forêt
sa superficie totale c'est de 5.5
millions de kilomètres carrés là dessus
il ya 60% de la forêt qui se trouve au
brésil mais elle est quand même menacé
par la déforestation et les feux de
forêt il ya des données de la nasa qui
qu'on peut voir sur la carte en ce
moment c'est de données satellites qui
ont été pris au cours des derniers jours
on voit l'amérique du sud et tout ce qui
était en rouge sur la carte c'est les
fleurs qui sont actifs en amérique du
sud dans la région en ce moment donc
c'est assez assez impressionnant selon
oui c'est assez impressionnant six
majeur effectivement selon les instituts
brésilien ces flots sont en hausse de 84
% comparativement à la même période l'an
dernier selon la nasa que pris ces
données les de leurs données vers un peu
plus certaines régions sont comme le
sont sont comme les autres années mais
le sud du brésil est vraiment et on
remarquait aussi une hausse des feux de
forêt dans cette région là est bon mais
si ces flux sont ces feux sont
importants mais on peut se demander est
ce que là ce que ça peut endommager la
forêt au long terme dans présentement
elle est encore capable de se régénérer
plus encore s'en remettre mais les
mécanismes qui j'ai la croissance des
plantes en affaires amazonienne sont
extrêmement délicat et si on continue
comme ça on va proches environs font en
fait on voit tout dérégler parce que il
pour exister dans sa forme actuelle la
forêt amazonienne au besoin d'énormément
dos et aulas va venir d'ailleurs de
nuages qui qui viennent des océans par
exemple une bonne partie cette eau là
qui vont être produites par la forêt
elle-même donc la forêt est capable de
générer sa propre pluie et sa propre
météo
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui arrive
parce que bon les plans vont toujours
les lots du sol et puis elles vont en
remettre une partie dans l'atmosphère
par transpiration mais la forêt
amazonienne est tellement grande
et elle est tellement dense que cette
transpiration elle va former des
nouveaux nuages au dessus de la forêt et
l'eau va retomber ensuite en pluie sur
la forêt amazonienne
on dit qu'elle peut se régénérer elle
même si ça en fait un peut s'alimenter
elle même en nous on pense que jusqu'à
50 % de toute la pluie qui tombe sur la
forêt tropicale peut vient justement de
cette deviennent de la forêt elle-même
mais si on continue la coupe et ce
mécanisme le vote des régles il y aura
un problème en fait c'est ça qu'est ce
qui arrive si c'est cette vie règle
c'est selon ce qu'on risque de voir ce
que ce qui risque d'arriver c'est que la
forêt vont progressivement se
transformer en savane et ça ce serait
une catastrophe pour la biodiversité une
catastrophe écologique
immense mais ce serait aussi un problème
un problème humanitaire majeure parce
que faut il vous rappeler que toute
cette pluie l'oeil a pas que la forêt
qui en bénéficie toute l'agriculture au
brésil on a besoin aussi
il ya aussi plusieurs pays autour du
brésil qui va dépendre de cette pluie là
pour être approvisionnés en eau et toute
la chaleur et l'humidité qui au dessus
de la forêt amazonienne
mais ça a une influence aussi sur les
courants aériens qui passe au-dessus
l'amérique du sud et sa salle a des
répercussions sur le climat mondial donc
si on continue endommagé la forêt ça
travaux des conséquences partout à
travers le monde
donc des conséquences également sur les
changements climatiques effectivement
passe présentement la forêt conseillers
comme un puits de carbone donc les
toutes les plantes dans le monde absorbe
à chaque année environ 25% de toute la
production des gaz à effet de serre qui
sont faits par l'être humain la forêt
amazonienne à elle seule est responsable
de 7 à 14% totale là mais si on continue
endommagé la forêt pourrait plutôt
devenir un émetteur de gaz à effet de
serre et on pense que environ 5 à 6 fois
toute la production mondiale de gaz à
effet de serre se trouve séquestrée dans
les arbres il sort de la forêt
amazonienne
mais ce sera pour être lâché ces mots
continue de l'endommager ce soit que
tous les effets négatifs que je dis
depuis tout à l'heure où paris vit du
jour au lendemain mais ça ça va être de
savoir faire sur aux locaux du prochain
siècle mais ce sera négatif pour les
changements climatiques pour rien comme
le maquereau g7 demande une concertation
avec suffisance pour essayer de trouver
une solution si d'aller aider au brésil
on le dit dans ce réduit le l'armée
pourra pas faire de miracles contre ça
est ce qu'on sait à quel moment on
atteindrait un point de non retour
selon les études le point de non retour
valentin qu'on a occupé entre 20 et 25 %
de la forêt tropicale brésilienne
on en est proche parce que jusqu'au
depuis des années 70 on en a coupé 18%
il ya eu des progrès dans les années
2015 j'en avais annoncé qu'on avait
réduit de 66 % le rite la déforestation
mais tout ça a changé depuis l'élection
du président gérard boys et nervo
d'ailleurs selon l'institut de
recherches spatiales nationales spatiale
brésilienne la déforestation en juin
elles avaient augmenté de 88%
compartiment l'an dernier de deux cent
soixante dix huit pour cent en juillet
comparativement au même mois
mais quand ces données là sont sortis le
président positionner roddick c'est un
mensonge et après quelques semaines de
tensions ils ont renvoyé le directeur de
cet institut la très bien alors on
comprend quel point c'est important puis
pourquoi il ya des inquiétudes aussi
grande à travers le monde par rapport à
cette forêt amazonienne en sont les
enjeux sont élevés merci beaucoup et
très plaisir